Cat problems. Pet problems is a genre.
Many people like to use it to frame various common tutorial problems.
If you go far enough with these, you end up with error correcting codes.
Of course your smartphone depends on those.
But today I'm just going to show you several hat problems. The two hat problem,
uh, involves two people.
Each of whom is going to have a blue or a red hat placed on their
head by an impartial referee.
Who's going to flip a coin to determine whether I'm going to have a blue hat or
a oops.
A red hat.
So you're wearing a blue or red and I'm playing to I that's right.
You have a bluer red on my head. I can't see it.
Here.
You might imagine me doing that and looking up like that.
And that's not allowed. In fact, if this are being played for money,
we would each be locked in a jail cell with a TV screen.
And the only thing we would see is our names. And under your name,
I would see a hat and under my name, I would see a choice.
I can predict my hair color. I can say either blue or red.
Let me talk you through a game. Okay?
So the hats have been placed on our head by a referee.
And now I see your hat and I'm supposed to, first of all,
predict my hat color on a signal. It's simultaneous with your prediction.
We each make a prediction of our hat color. I haven't seen mine,
which means my prediction is 50 50. Your prediction is 50 50.
Because both of our hats were randomly chosen.
And the choice isn't connected in any way.
The choice is not connected. The referee flipped the coin for each one.
There are four possible ways. The hats could be there. Two reds, blue, red, red,
blue, and two blues. We make a prediction,
but the goal is a little unusual.
The goal is that exactly. One of us is right there when we succeed,
if you're right and I'm wrong, or vice versa, we fail.
If we're both wrong or both, right?
So one of us has to be right.
One of us has to be wrong about the color on our own head.
This looks awfully challenging.
I guess about my head color is just a guess.
It has 50% chance of success.
Your guest's has 50% chance of success.
And the goal is not only to try to
be one right, one wrong, but to get that all the time,
somehow combining these 50 fifties and coming up with certainty,
certainly sounds impossible. At first glance, once you see the idea,
you'll see that your mental image of that was not right.
Right.
Okay. Here's the winning strategy.
The night before we that on the following,
you will be agreeable and you will say whatever color you
see, and I.
Will say red, you're wearing, I'm wearing red.
So you're going to say red. And on the other hand,
I'm going to be disagreeable.
And I will say the opposite of what I see and you're wearing blue.
So I'm going to say red Berg, both going to save red in that circumstance,
you can make a table and figure out why there's always going to be one of us.
Correct. But if you think about it, there's a very intuitive reason.
I'm betting that that colors are opposite and you being
much more agreeable are betting that the colors are the same.
And so therefore, clearly one of us is right. And one of us is wrong.
What if the grooves of the game had been that we both have to be right?
Could we have had a winning strategy? Then.
If we both have to be right, there is just no way we can do it.
And so there's something about this particular set of rules that enables this
magic trick, three hats.
There's a famous three hat problem that arose about 20 years ago.
I got a lot of press. And let me describe that one to you.
There are now three players, Alice, Bob, and Charlie,
and the rules are still,
we're going to have hats place randomly on our heads.
We are not allowed to communicate. Once that's done at a bell,
say 10 seconds. After the hats are replaced,
the three possible answers are red, blue, and pass.
And those are predictions for my hat color.
And of course the rules include the fact that everybody sees to add colors,
but not their own. And maybe I should have this off.
I like it. But anyway, it's up to you. What's the idea to win the game here.
So here, uh,
each of the three of us makes a prediction or passes and
we win.
If there are no incorrect predictions and
at least somebody makes a prediction or we lose.
If anybody says something wrong,
or if everybody passes have to scratch your head a little about that,
but it's actually a fairly natural.
So at least one person has to make a guess.
And everyone who makes a guess must be.
That's right? So if we do that,
we're all freed from jail or get a million dollars. Pick your favorite reward.
It depends on your current circumstance.
You might start thinking of some strategies, one that you might take,
if you didn't have a strategy session, was everybody guesses. Okay.
Let's think about that. Alice,
Bob and Charlie each make a guess by the rules. Namely,
each hat is randomly chosen.
Each of those has probability of one half of being, right?
So the chance that we would win with that strategy is one out of eight.
If you think about it a little bit, it would be better.
If just one person say Alice guest,
one reasonable strategy is Bob and Charlie pass Alice guesses.
Now that comes down to a coin flip Alice's betting on her hat color.
So she has one and two or a 50% chance of being right.
Okay. Well, that's a key strategy.
It may seem that nothing better can be done. Why is that?
Because anybody who doesn't pass and somebody has to not pass is
making a 50, 50 guests.
So that almost seems like it's a proof that you can't do any better.
There's no connection between the hats. There's no quantum entanglement here,
like, like the hats are all completely independent, random.
The hats are all placed by a coin flip.
So how could anything, uh, improve one half,
improve the profitability of one person guessing
There is an amazing strategy. The first time you see it,
that gives you a chance, three out of four of winning.
And that's 75% and you can't do any better than that.
So you're not always going to win this game. It's not like the two person game,
but three quarters seems pretty amazing, but let's start with the strategy.
Then I'm going to do of all things, drug cube,
and walk you through how you could have come up with that strategy.
Here's the strategy, your two friends, you don't know your head color.
If you see two hats of the same color,
you say the opposite may seem a little odd.
That's what you say. So if you see two blues, you say I've got.
That's right. If you see two hats of opposite color,
one blue and one red you pass,
I actually want to work you through how you might come up with this answer.
Really? There are two cases. Let's think about what happens.
If all three hats are the same color. If all three hats have the same color.
For instance, everybody like me has a red hat on.
According to this strategy, we all say blue.
The only other case is two ads of one color.
And the third hat of the other color,
let's think about what happens in that case. Alice, Bob,
and Charles have these color hats. What is going to happen?
Both Alice and Bob each see one hat at each color.
So they're going to pass. What about Charles?
Charles sees two hats of that color and he announces the opposite
color red. So now that's a win.
Now we have to ask the following interesting question. First of all,
how many ways are there to place the hats?
There's two choices for each of the three players. Two times,
two times two means there's eight ways to place those hats.
How many are there and where the hats are all the same color to all blue,
all red. Those are cases where you're going to fail.
You have a one quarter chance of failing.
The other six cases are all the two and one. And in that case, you succeed.
So your winning strategy is to do this and you win
with probability three.
Easy peasy, easy peasy. I don't know what you're talking about. Cubes and stuff,
or this is like, this is just, this is sorted. Yeah, it's cute. So.
As far,
what I want to try to do is give you a feeling about how to think about it and
how you might come up with it. Brady and SIS, I draw pictures.
So I'm going to draw a picture of a cube. Um, here's a cube now of course,
your immediate reaction is what does this have to do with anything? Well,
we agreed. There are eight possible hat, placements being a mathematician.
It's very hard for me to keep track of colors like blue and red.
All I can keep track of zeros and ones.
So I'm going to label these with all possible triples of
zeros in ones. Okay.
And they're labeling the vertices of the cube and, and, uh,
Brady's being kind to not pointing out that I didn't label this one.
And if you look at it carefully, you'll see that any adjacent vertices,
different one symbol, uh, fine here.
One zero one and one zero, zero.
Is that the reason that the triple zero and the triple one are at opposite ends
of the queue?
Uh, they are, as far apart, you have to make three changes. One, two, three.
Of course, you can make those in, in many different ways,
but they have to be antipodal. So why are we looking at this? Well,
these correspond to the half placements,
and now suppose that you were Charles.
I claim if you see two blue hats and blue is zero and
red is one. You don't know whether you have red or blue.
In some sense,
you are sitting on that edge of the cube and you want to know what to do.
Your choices are to name a hat color or pass.
I'm going to put a dot on the edges in which you should pass and an
arrow. So we know what Charles did.
He said red,
I'm recording the strategy on this cube. And here,
Alice says red here. Bob says red here,
Charles sees two alike and therefore says the opposite.
So there's this funny picture that emerges
what's happening here. Okay. Who is this? Well,
the coordinate that changes is Alice.
So Alice sees blue and red.
So she knows that she's supposed to pass six edges have labels and
the other six are all passes.
Somehow the magical secret of this is there two landmines
here and here. These are the times we lose the million dollars.
These are the hat placements,
and we don't want to step on a landmine.
So we predict we aren't on the land mine.
And maybe rather than saying, we're not trying to step on it.
What we're really saying is that the landmine happens. We all three,
want to get blown up at the same time. The magic way we've converted.
These coin flips into a three quarters advantage is to having all the correct
answers in separate cases.
And the incorrect answers happen in two cases where everybody is incorrect.
So if we have more than three players,
the situation starts getting interesting. Let's consider four players.
Well, one thing we know we can do in that case is in our strategy session.
Dave agrees to pass and Alice,
Bob and Charlie play this game.
And what that means is the probability that team of four,
with that strategy is three quarters. Rather, surprisingly,
they can't do any better than that. If there are five people,
there's a more complicated strategy. That is a little better.
It's it's messier than this one is how I would describe it.
Same with six people, all of a sudden with seven people.
There's a nice strategy. Again, it's not quite as easily described as this,
but it gives you the best possible probability of success.
If you work through what's happening here,
the property that makes this work is that these two points
are adjacent to every point on the cube. Why is that necessary?
Well, if you're talking about strategies and other is labeling in this way,
it turns out that if you have a losing position,
you might as well have all arrows coming out from it.
And the next little thing I'm leaving this for you to figure out in your mind,
every Vertex either has to be in that losing set
or adjacent to it. Okay?
So now you can draw a four-dimensional cube. Well, what would that be?
What is a four-dimensional cube? Um,
it would have vertices labeled by all strings of length,
four symbols of zeros in one they're 16 vertices.
And there's a lot of ways to draw that,
but it really doesn't matter whether or not you can visualize these higher
dimensional cubes. All you have to think about is these strings, zeros and ones.
So this makes,
gives you some way to at least think about the problem for any number of
players.
What if everyone in the world was playing? So.
So the magic numbers like seven,
our powers of two minus one. And for those,
these magic sets are completely explicit and they're called
Hemmings single error, correcting codes.
They're perfect codes because they touch everything perfectly without
duplication.
Professor does that mean when we get to 15 players and when we get to
31 players, we see sudden jumps in the probability of winning well.
So when you come to 15 players,
you can describe a very nice solution.
If we could find the best possible ones after that,
the probability would slowly increase until at 31. It would again be nice.
In fact, the numbers right below 31, it's not known what the best number is.
So your probability winning is only going to go up,
but it's as elegant elegant solution within is a power of two minus one
of those places that failure probability is one over well in
plus one, one over that power of two. So with 31 players,
our chance of failing is one of our 32.
Our chances of winning is 31 over 32. If it was the population of the planet,
our chance of losing would be one over, well, I don't know, 4 billion.
Let's say it's distinctive feature is that all the
players have infinitely many hats.
Each one of them equally likely to be blue or red.
So here is just the beginning, uh, inflamed, many hats.
That would go all the way, all the way up to the ceiling.
And through, and now, um, maybe if they get smaller,
it will only have finite height.
So now the game sounds pretty impossible.
You have some number of players, each players of course sees every.